well you should be afraid of taking
risks and pursuing something meaningful
but you should be more afraid of staying
where you are if it's making you
miserable so you have to go just to know
and it may not work yet I know rise and
shine it since presto time
good morning belief nation my name's
Lily and my one word is extraordinary I
believe that every single human being is
capable of extraordinary things when
they embrace who they truly are so let's
start your day off right together go
grab yourself a cup of coffee and step
on today's message pursue what's
meaningful over to you
Jordan B Peterson you arrived in the
book there is no faith and no courage
and no sacrifice in doing what is
expedient what do you say to those
viewers that don't pursue their dreams
and are locked into their careers
because they are too afraid to take
risks and pursue something meaningful
well the first thing I would say is well
you should be afraid of taking risks and
pursuing something meaningful but you
should be more afraid of staying where
you are if it's making you miserable
it's like the first thing you want to do
is dispense with the idea that you get
to have any any permanent security
outside of your ability to contend and
adapt it's the same issue with children
it's like you're paying a price by
sitting there being miserable and you
might say well the devil I know is
better than the one I don't it's like
don't be so sure of that
the clock is ticking yeah and if you're
miserable in your job now and you change
nothing in five years you'll be much
more miserable and you'll be a lot older
but this into the luxury to pursue what
is meaningful our viewers have mortgages
they have children yeah they have
payments and loans it's a luxury to
pursue because we lack the resources
well I don't think I don't remember now
I'm not talking about what makes you
happy it's a luxury to pursue what makes
you happy it's a moral obligation
Gatien to pursue what you find
meaningful and that doesn't mean it's
easy it might require sacrifice if you
need to change your job - let's say you
have family and and and and children and
a mortgage you have responsibilities
you've already picked up those
responsibilities you don't just get to
walk away scot-free and say well I don't
like my job I quit
that's no strategy but what you might
have to do is you think well this job is
killing my soul all right so what do I
have to do about that well I have to
look for another job well no one wants
to hire me it's like okay maybe you need
to educate yourself more maybe you need
to update your your curriculum vitae
your resume maybe you need to overcome
your fear of being interviewed maybe you
need to sharpen your social skills like
you you have to think about these things
strategically if you're going to switch
careers you have to do it like an
intelligent responsible person that
might take you a couple of years of of
effort I've dealt with hundreds of
people in my clinical and consulting
practice and we set a goal we develop a
vision and work towards it and things
inevitably get better for people so it's
not a luxury it's it's difficult it's a
moral responsibility and it isn't
happiness it's it's not the pursuit
isn't for happiness it's a moral
responsibility to push you what is
meaningful absolutely it's really hard
to pursue what's meaningful and the
problem is is with a question of the
interviewer the interviewer is saying
that isn't it a luxury to pursue
something that's meaningful and that
makes it seem like there's only a chosen
few that could have a meaningful life
and it's all happiness and joy and
everything is amazing and easy the
reality is it's really hard and it's
hard and painful to let go of things
that are sort of good that feels
comfortable for example having a
comfortable job like what Jordan was
talking about and staying there and
continue to be miserable as time goes on
and not leaving that and you know the
thing is people think that oh you just
leave your job and everything is great
and you're happy that's not the truth
and I'm gonna share something that I
have not shared and this is the first
time I'm sharing something like this is
last night at a conversation with my
ex-husband
I was feeling very lonely and because
I'm about to leave the country and I'm
by myself at home and I'm trying to
figure out all of the scheduling crap
and and trying to make things work and
afraid that my business is about to fail
and he just felt so comfortable for me
he felt like he was the person grounding
me for the first time I've hadn't had
that feeling with anybody and I start
thinking to myself like why did I
divorce this man why can't I just go
back to that as comfortable as good
actually just completely cancel my trip
to Thailand and not worry about anything
and just keep everything comfortable and
good and keep being happy in that moment
that's how I felt and I was having the
conversation with him I realized what am
I gonna regret more am I gonna regret
not being in a relationship with someone
that was good for me that felt good or
am I gonna regret not going into the
unknown and pursuing this giant
adventure with someone I don't even know
and trying to make my business work I'm
gonna regret the second thing it's not
pursuing something that's meaningful
just because it's hard and it's
inconvenient for me and that's a thing
for you what does the vision of
something that's meaningful for you is
it going on a giant adventure is it
creating a business that is Purpose
Driven is it having an amazing
relationship what does that look for you
and it's not going to be easy let me
just tell you that you would have to
acquire certain skills to get there it's
not like you have this vision of
something that comes comes to life and
you expect that the universe is just
gonna give it to you you will have to
develop skills yes it's exciting I'm
going to a brand new country I'm gonna
pursue the unknown I'm gonna continue my
business that way but there are tons of
skills that I need to develop to get
there I need to be that much better as a
coach I need to be that much better my
communication skills I need to be that
much better in disciplining myself and
staying to a strict schedule and it's
all gonna be hard but it's all worth it
so for you write down three things that
is meaningful for you and
cite each one write down five skills
that you need to develop to get there
because it's not only having this
amazing vision that is meaningful for
you it's also taking action towards it
to make that happen
just remember it's gonna be really hard
but it's worth it when you pursue what's
meaningful
reporter Harnett good for me I'm just
having so many does yeah I don't know if
I should I just don't know I was close
to canceling it so you have to go just
to know and it may not work yet okay I
know it'll be regrets what you just said
so you just said you're gonna regret it
if you don't do it when people have to
go through and then you can coach other
peoples in the process I know I know
it's it all makes sense I just diced
it's massively inconvenient for me to go
right now it's never convenient what
kind of argument is that I know it was
my Instagram coke today it's good you're
eating your own dog food you're taking
the advice that you would give and it'll
make the advice you give even stronger
okay well I have to wrap this up oh my
god it's still recording yes okay well I
was gonna go with another story this is
a better story okay what am I saying
okay we do this every time guys now I
have a special bonus clip for you but
before we get to that the question of
the day is what is the most painful part
of your purpose that makes you wanna cry
leave in the comments below and I'll
join in on the discussion thank you so
much for watching I believe in you and
hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is and we'll
see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot of in space
and now enjoy the bonus clips
I I think you should be doing something
you're passionate about so the question
is always you know when I give my
younger self advice you know what I
still go to Stanford which still go to
Stanford Law School possibly but I think
a lot more about why I was doing it was
is it just you know and I was on this
super tracked here myself
ended up at a big law firm in New York
in my eighth grade junior high school
yearbook one of my friends wrote and I
know you're gonna get into Stanford in
four years I went to Stanford four years
later went to Stanford Law School ended
up at a big law firm in in New York
we're on the outside everybody wanted to
get in on the inside everybody wanted to
get out when I left after seven months
and three days one of the one of the
people are down the hall from me said it
was you know really reassuring to see it
was possible to escape from Alcatraz
which you know and all you do is really
just go out the front door but but so
much of our identity gets wrapped up in
the competitions we win and on that and
when you compete and I think a lot of
the credentialing resume building is
this sort of competition when you
compete you do get better at what you're
competing at if you take lots of SAT
test prep classes you'll get a better
school on the SAT and when you compete
you get better at beating people on the
narrow things you need to beat them on
but but you often it it often comes at
this very high price of of losing sight
of what's what's truly valuable and
important and meaningful which is well I
think passion is well there's sort of
all sorts of other there all sorts of
things that that could be that but but I
think I think it often that I think it
often ends up being something that's a
little bit off the beaten path because I
think you know there's obviously
financial where you get to be have a
monopoly like business there's a
meaningful version I think is always
counterfactual where if you weren't
doing this would you know it's great to
be working on problems where if you
weren't working on them nobody else
would do them you know if you're working
at the fourth online pet food company
the 10th in film solar panel company the
1000th restaurant in Philadelphia
there's a sense that if you weren't
doing it someone else would you know if
you're working
at at something where it's the only
thing of its kind in the world that's
very meaningful if we weren't if we
won't end it to be for-profit nonprofit
all sorts of contexts if we weren't
doing this this problem would absolutely
not be tackled I think that's the kind
of that that's what's that's what's
meaningful raise your standard Apple at
the core its core value is that we
believe that people with passion can not
one drop of myself work depends on
Europe it's suppose to mean I don't ever
give up I'd have to be dead or
completely incapacitated hey believe
nation if you want to see my all-time
favorite top ten most a success I have a
very special secret video for you these
are the individual clips that I have
personally learned the most from and
applied to my life and my business check
the link in description for details